[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar techniques and tips learn sample
preparation for next generation
sequencing
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
delanka jayawara manager r d molecular
biology thermo fisher scientific
zuli kelvikar scientist r d molecular
biology thermo fisher scientific
and andrew dick's staff scientist r d
protein and cell analysis thermo fisher
scientific
you may now begin your presentations
hi my name is andrew dix i am a staff
scientist with thermo fisher scientific
and today is my pleasure to talk to you
about methods for dna quantification
specifically for next-gen sequencing
users
so regardless of what sequencing
technology you're utilizing whether
that's adapter based sequencing
massively parallel sequencing or
long-range sequencing they're going to
be a variety of quantification steps uh
in your workflow and having the highest
the highest quality quantification is
going to only lead to better sequencing
so here today i hope to talk to you
about some tips and tricks to get the
most out of that information to
ultimately ultimately lead to better
sequencing data
for better or worse unfortunately there
isn't a one size one-size-fits-all
approach to quantification so i want to
highlight a few different technologies
and they're pros some trade-offs
starting with the nano drop
spectrophotometer this is going to be uv
based detection and it'll give you your
broadest range of sensitivity
it will give you it's a low throughput
system and it will give you results in
under two minutes and it also can nicely
give you some purity information using
an a260 a2 a280 ratio
alternatively on the other end of the
spectrum so that's really nice for look
for high concentration samples for low
abundant samples
there's uh qpcr so qpcr is great for
amplification unfortunately it requires
known primers so it will not work for
every workflow but it will
as it is based on fluorescence it will
give you that highest sensitivity and
highest selectivity
what we find works best for most users
is going to be
the cubit the qubit flex or similarly
the quant
setups these are going to again be based
on fluorescence that will give you that
highest sensitivity and selectivity
there are various options for throughput
and can get you results between 5 and 10
minutes
these will also be sequence independent
so regardless of where you're at in your
workflow
this is something that you can utilize
so a typical library of prep as
normalized here is going to be about
0.1 to 10 nanograms per microliter as
far as sample concentration goes and
this is going to be on
shaded to the low end of the nanodrop
spectrophotometer spectrophotometers
detection range so only about 30
of users or for samples are going to be
able to get that quality information
utilizing this approach
again on the alternative side for qpcr
if you're doing a low abundant sample
because you have this extra dilution
step to get to your qpcr workflow you
can really nicely get those low abundant
samples because you have that
amplification
for most users we find well over 80 of
most users and their samples the dna
high sensitivity assays are going to be
right in that
prime library detection range and have
the most overlap and that's most of what
i'll be talking to you about today is
the dna high sensitivity assay that is
offered through the cubit cubic flex and
the quantity plate reader systems
as i mentioned before this is based on
fluorescence to get that sensitivity and
selectivity
these assays will all detect in this
case dna double-stranded dna in the
presence of
oligomers
nucleotides
proteins or anything else your master
mix or your dna isolation kit might
throw at you
each of those systems is predicated on a
add mix read workflow that is designed
to be
user friendly and
to have high ease of use
they will all start with preparing the
working solution so in the classic assay
format the users will combine a provided
dmso
die stock solution with buffer to create
the working solution
our newly released 1x asset format for
the
want for the high sensitivity and broad
range systems will streamline this
process for you
and at that point you will
treat your dna standards as well as your
samples with the working solution you've
either been provided or you've created
uh to read on your
instrument of choice whether that's the
cubic fluorometer for a more iterative
throughput the cubic flex fluorometer
for more medium throughput or the
quantity assay for a higher throughput
so i want to highlight a few on-board
instrument features on the qubit flex
thermiter that are built specifically
towards next-gen sequencing users
first and foremost is the sample
preparation calculator we're well aware
that most users are using only one and
two microliters of sample
and this might augment the detection
range so here's a nice before you begin
check to make sure your
presumed sample range fits in with the
detection range you're utilizing
the next screen is going to be a
pictorial representation of where your
sample concentration
as determined fits into the dynamic
range on the left you'll see the low end
detection so if your sample falls where
that left red dot is
you might want to either consider using
more sample if you have the ability to
or look towards an alternative method
like pcr to get that extra sensitivity
on the flip side on the right end if you
see that top right red dot that's going
to be that your sample is too high
outside of the sensitivity range and you
might want to consider
further dilution or in this case you're
using a dna high sensitivity assay you
might want to consider using a broad
right now range assay
some other downstream so once you've
done your concentration some other nice
features are the molarity calculator
so if you've done your
if you've done if you've determined your
dna length using an electrophoresis
technique like a tape station or a
bioanalyzer you can input that
dna length into this calculator and
convert all of your concentrations into
molarity
you can even go one step further with
the normalization calculator for sample
pooling which will be common for your
adapter-based sequencing technologies
and approaches
and say i want a final concentration of
five millimolar in this case and the
system will determine the recipe for you
which is a really nice onboard check
taking a step
towards the higher throughput quant
assays these are built for plate raters
each of these kits is provided with a
eight point
standard curve solution
and
that's highlighted here with the black
dots on the main graph
where the ideal
concentration so when the expected dna
concentration on the x-axis matches
perfectly
the calculated dna concentration on the
y-axis
any values typically
in that space between your standard
curve so between your standard one and
your standard eight are generally going
to be within 10 of expected and
generally going to be very well behaved
what we find most users are frustrated
by is what happens below that space and
that space
not matching what they might have seen
on a cubic ferometer or a cubic flex
and we find that a lot of those users
are using linear regression which is
highlighted in the top right
and just by nature of this curve fitting
model
it's not really focused on the low end
it's mostly focused on high end and you
can get as much as 50 error highlighted
in this graph here
where those
sample measurements where n equals four
are notably lower than your ideal line
which is that solid line that's shown
we strongly recommend using background
correction
and
ideally a quadratic model
the background correction can be done by
simply subtracting the blank from all of
your samples
and fixing your y-intercept to zero
alternatively you can set your
y-intercept to the
rfu's of your blank measurement for
example if that's 23 you can set that to
23
and that'll tidy up your data at the low
end and allow you to get
really nicely within the expected
concentration so about 10 percent
of what you'd expect and what you'd
expect from a
cubit fluorometer when you're measuring
the same samples
for users that want to take it one step
further there's automation so liquid
handling
if this is compatible with 96 or 3d4
well plates
we've been able to show
really nice data taking this using 40
microliters of a final volume in a 384
well plate
uh but please keep in mind again towards
the tips and tricks that if you're doing
this you're cutting that volume by a
fifth so going from 200 microliters to
40 you'll in turn need to take your die
concentration and multiply that by 5 to
offset the change in volume
similarly if you were cutting your
volume in half you need to double your
dye concentration
and
when this is done you'll be able to
match that sensitivity
and dynamic range that's expected and
reported on the website
for users they want to go even further
than liquid handling automation there's
the newly released genexis purification
system
which is an all-in-one
sample isolation and purification to
quantification and sample pooling
instrument this is for true hands-free
automation
and this is going to be powered by the
cubit assay so you'll get the same
performance selectivity and confidence
that you would have as if you were using
the cubit instrument
more information for this as well as
other systems can be found online
through our website
and so with that i want to recap
highlighted here on the left are going
to be some
some of the high level points that i
really like to drive home
the and also on the right is going to be
sources for additional information
whether that's from our website uh links
to customer support if you need to talk
to someone directly
i also have highlighted a few key
application notes that i think are
really pertinent to this audience
the one i really want to highlight is
how pipetting choice and volume can
affect the results for your nucleic acid
quantification
this is specifically interesting in my
opinion for users that are working with
two microliter volumes or less
because the choice in pipetting
instrument can actually have a profound
impact on your
variance
and lastly i just want to say thank you
for your time we know there are a lot of
options when doing dna quantification
we're here to help
please reach out if you need anything
else again through the channels that
were listed before
and
i hope this helps
happy sequencing
thank you so much this is zueli kelvaker
today i am very excited to present to
you high throughput nucleic acid
extraction solutions for downstream
genomic applications that are offered by
thermo fischer scientific recent
development in nucleic acid extraction
procedures using diverse sample type has
opened the possibilities of using
various kinds of body fluids in research
applications currently for cancer and
other dc genome analysis there is a need
for high throughput rapid and accurate
nucleic acid extraction techniques
the applied biosystems
magnetic bead-based technology along
with kingfisher instrument can help
provide accurate and reliable nucleic
acid isolations that can be used in many
downstream applications like qpcr for
disease detection
genotyping to identify genetic disorder
ancestry prediction prediction and many
other diseases
here we are focusing on four main areas
the first one is tips and tricks for
efficient sample collection techniques
second one is uh semi to fully automated
kingfisher instrument for a nucleic acid
extraction third one is applied a
magnetic bead-based technology for
nucleic acid purification and the last
one is long-stream genomic application
using magmax kit and kingfisher
instrument this presentation i will be
covering several tips and tricks for
efficient sample collection techniques
first one is utilizing stabilized saliva
over raw saliva to improve downstream
sequencing performance second one is
using non-invasive sample type like
saliva that can produce concordant
results same as gold standard invasive
and sensitive sample type third one is
for liquid biopsy applications the
plasma quality purity and concentration
are crucial factors immobilized blood
sample can negatively impact the
downstream sequencing applications and
last one is i will be explaining high
quality of dna rna can be obtained from
either fresh frozen or ffpe samples
below is general
workflow for sample to answer using
magmax kit and iron torrent ngs workflow
it includes sample collection using
thermo-fisher sample processing devices
followed by sample digestion and
beta-based nucleic acid isolation using
magmax chemistry and kingfisher
instrument
for downstream sequencing applications
the template preparation and sequencing
can be performed on iron torrent
instrument and also on standalone
genexis sequencer finally data can be
analyzed using iron reporter to align
with this sample to answer workflows
thermo fisher scientific is offering
several sample collection devices
uh like magmax purification kits and
instrument nucleic acid detection assays
and this devices to determine quality of
extracted nucleic acid and next
generation iron torrent sequencing
instruments and as well as assays and
some of them are listed here
here are several instruments that are
available in market for high tool uh so
for low to high throughput sample
processing techniques the first one is
kingfisher duo prime which is standalone
compact bench top with low to medium
throughput and can process 6 to 12
samples per run second one is kingfisher
flex which can process 24 to 96 samples
per run and it is medium to high
throughput kingfisher apex is a modified
version of kingfisher flakes with added
functionalities like q sterilization
dual magnetic heat uh magnetic head
heating plate for 924 to 96 sample
extraction
plate barcode reader and user friendly
gui the last one is kingfisher playstore
which is benched off with integrated
robotic liquid handler for high to ultra
hydroput extractions
so here i will be uh focusing on
sarcobic 2 sequencing performance using
raw and stabilized saliva samples
match raw and stabilize sellers and
were collected from 10 healthy human
donor using specimen saliva sample
collection kit and spiked in with
inactivated bi control at 12 500 copies
per ml
the extraction of sars cover to rna was
done using magnex spiral pythogen 2 on
nucleic acid extraction kit on
kingfisher instrument
the turnaround time from sample
collection to nucleic acid extraction
496 sample was around one hour
rt pcr was performed using thermo
fischer tagpad chemistry on extracted
rna to confirm the presence of sars ob2
for downstream sequencing perform
applications libraries were constructed
using iron mp6 sars copy 2
insight research assay panel
templates were prepared on iron chef and
sequencing was performed ingen studio s5
system
finally data was analyzed on iron
reporter
the real length histogram reveals
similar profiles across all contrived
raw and stabilized saliva samples
main railing did not show any trend
across all controlled raw as well as
stabilized samples
however the contrived saliva from
stabilized uh sorry however the
contrived samples from stabilized saliva
showed cleaner histogram as compared to
raw samples
here you will notice for donor 15 the
sali uh the raw saliva histogram has a
lot of byproducts as compared to
stabilized specimen so to at the end
conclude the stabilized saliva show
better downstream performance as
compared to ross 11.
okay so currently several techniques and
sample types are being used for nucleic
acid extractions including uh lava
sample fluid lower sample nasal swab
brush biopsies mesopharyngeal swab
saliva blood etc
of this saliva has emerged as a
promising sample type for diagnosis of
infectious diseases and genetic
applications as it is non-invasive
sample collection technique
the applied biosystems magmax dna
multi-sample ultra 2.0 kit can be used
to extract nucleic acids containing
genomic dna from multiple sample types
the extraction can be automated by
pairing the magmax dna kit with magnetic
bead-based purification system
here whole blood buckle swab and saliva
samples were collected from 25 male and
four female donors ranging in age range
of 21 to 67 years dna extraction from
whole blood and saliva were performed
using 400 microliter sample input
whereas one buckle swap per donor was
used all dn extractions were performed
using magnex dna multi-sample ultra 2.0
kit and on kingfisher instrument
the sample to nucleic acid isolation
turned around time was around 1 over 30
minutes
the integrity and purity of extracted
with dna were determined using nanodrop
and qubit
for genotyping all extractions were
normalized to 5 nanogram per microliter
and frequency libraries were prepared
with iron
zone ready kit
templates were prepared on iron shape
and sequence sequencing was performed on
gene studio s5 and finally the data was
analyzed using iron reporter
in first graph
the tacman assay were used for
genotyping of three snip two of which
are found to be uh within the genes
associated with drug metabolism
the genotyping percent core rate for
heterozygous which is represented in
blue homozygous allele 1 which is
represented in orange homozygous allele
2 which is represented in gray were
detected with three snips assays where
in concordance with each sample type
in the second graph
it indicates the variant calling
concordance which is greater than 98
percent across all sequence sample types
and also within shared locale which
indicates consistent calling
functionalities across all sample types
on average less than two percent share
local had one inconsistent variant and
less than zero point zero three percent
share loci had three inconsistent
variants
between match donor samples
to conclude that
at the end that non-invasive sample type
like saliva sample collection can be
can be used to circumvent the more
invasive sample collection technique
like you like but uh sorry like whole
blood or buckle swab
liquid biofc is a less invasive
companion to traditional tumor biopsies
as for next generation sequencing for
circular cell free nucleic acid is
becoming common it is important to
understand the impact of sample
preparation on quality specificity and
sensitivity of liquid biopsy
in this study we explored the effect of
sub optimal plasma and low library input
on ngs applications
the keto eta plasma was collected from
four healthy donors including one normal
control and two hemolyzed sample nucleic
acid isolation was performed on 4 ml
plasma from each donor using magmax cell
free total nucleic acid isolation kit
yield and quality of isolated cell free
nucleic acid were assessed using a qubit
as well as agilent type station
for library input concentration study 5
10 and 20 nanogram of nucleic acid input
was used to prepare ngs library using
iron amplistic cancer
hotspot panel v2
templates were prepared on iron chef and
sequencing was performed on ingn studio
s5 system to compare ngis metrics
including
red length molecular coverage and limit
of detection
for hemolysis study whole blood from
three healthy donor were collected in k2
irritate tubes
for normal conditions tubes were spun
down to separate plasma immediately for
moderate hemolysis condition tubes were
vortex until hemolysis was reached to
220 to fill uh 50 milligram per
deciliter and for high hemolysis tubes
were vertex and
until the hemolysis was uh reached 200
to 200 milligram per deciliter
cell free nucleic acid isolation was
performed using 4 ml of plasma
the histogram
in figure a representing the real length
for each library
as the library improved this decreases
the presence of small by-product
increases which is around
50 base pairs
the agilent tab station stresses in
figure c indicate small by-products and
main amplicon peak which were which are
visible
representative overlays for donor one
for library generated using fine
nanogram which is represented by red
10 nanogram which is represented by blue
and 20 nanogram which is represented by
green
for hemolysis study ngs libraries were
prepared using maximum volume input that
is 10.4 microliter per sample
a graph a on right indicates blue for
normal
green for moderate
hemolysis and gray for high hemolysis
the median absolute pairwise difference
quality control metric that is mapd was
higher for hemolyzed sample
the ion reporter qc threshold for mapd
which is less than 0.4
passed for all three donors for normal
plasma however it failed for four out of
six samples with high
with either moderate or high hemolysis
the mapd metric is important for cnv
that is copy number variant variation
detection which indicate that in table p
the hemolyse plasma may be negatively
impact cnv detection
as the plasma is from all healthy donor
no variants are detected for any sample
as per the table see
so to conclude at the end the low sample
input into ngs library reduces the mean
rate length
and
the result and in it results in increase
in byproduct also hemolysis negatively
impacts ngs uniformity and also
adversely affects cnv calling
okay here i will talk about the quality
purity and yield of nucleic acid uh that
is obtained from ffp as well as from
which is in compare which is comparable
to their match fresh frozen counterpart
here the nucleic acid extraction
extraction of nucleic acid from fresh
frozen tissue as well as ffp is a
critical step in
routine workflow for many research lab
however magmax ffp dna rna ultra kit
using magnetic separation technique can
help circumvent
by extracting both dna as well as rna
from single section of tissue
sample in single workflow
quality purity and integrity of
extracted dna and rna were determined
using nano drop and qubit
for njth applications the libraries were
constructed using iron implicit cancer
hotspot panel v2 followed by template
preparation on iron shift
the sequencing was performed on iron
gene studio s5 system and reports were
analyzed on iron reporter software
for this experiment lung cancer and
breast cancer sample were obtained from
three different patients
all frozen tissues were kept at minus 80
degree celsius except during grossing
and sectioning and immediately returned
to minus 80 degree celsius when possible
one section from each tissue a sample
was saved
to serve as fresh frozen control sample
and risk
rest of the tissues were
fixed and embedded
as per dna extraction graph there was a
comparable mean read length and high
mapping percentage for both
sample types that is fresh frozen as
well as ffp for both breasts as well as
lung cancer tissue
also on target percent
on target percentage were comparable
with slightly better results for fresh
frozen samples
on average 95.5 percent of the sequences
were on target for fresh and froze fresh
frozen tissues and
91.7 percent of for the ffbe sample
the percent uniformity was also
very comparable across all both sample
types
as per uh for the
rna extraction graph
mean relent for ffa sample were slightly
shorter than fresh frozen sample but
still it was about 110 base pair
the percent map was high yielding
comparable results of greater than 99
percent mac
the percent valid rate and percent read
on target were high yielding comparable
results of greater than 99.5 percent
as per table e the variant calling uh
the same hotspot mutations were called
with similar frequencies
so at the end to conclude that using
this work nucleic acid from fresh frozen
as well as ffp samples can be extracted
with sufficient yield purity quantity
and for many downstream genomic as well
as transfer transcriptomic analysis
here is the list of dna extraction kit
as well as rn extraction kit viral
bacterial extraction kit total nucleic
acid and metagenomic extraction kits
that are most commonly used by
researchers and for more information
please click on on this kit please click
on the click which is provided here
and at the end of this presentation i
would like to reference and acknowledge
the author of these app notes lilly
manley steve roman
zhaoping duan
natalie hernandez angie chang
yogi bordia tilanka jayavira
and with this thank you so much for your
attention and i am open to take any
questions
thank you everyone for joining today
i will introduce the genexis
purification system for sample
preparation for ngs
today i will
give you an overview of the genexis
system
focusing on the genexis purification
system and its
consumables
next
i will
show how to plan run and
load the deck
and how the system
helps
in that process
next i will walk you through the
ffve dna and rna purification workflow
and
cell free dna purification workflows
the ion tolerant genexis system is a two
part instrument
which contains the genexis purification
system and genexis integrated sequencer
this is a automated workflow from sample
to result which controlled by one
software the genexis software
however
these two instruments can be used as
standalone instruments
that are not connected to each other
the genexis purification system can
process different sample types such as
ffpe lysates plasma blood
and blood derived sample types
also
tissues and cells
so depending on number of samples and
sample types processed
the purification system can take up to
five and half hours for completion of
nucleic acid extraction and quantitation
as i mentioned the genexis purification
system can be
used as a standalone system
meaning that it is not connected to the
sequencer
and the nucleic acid
that you get out of the purification
system can be used for any downstream
application including
ngs platforms other than gen xs
the genexis purification system has a
user interface
to plan the run in standalone
mode
and also you can monitor your runs
through the screen
the instrument has a robotic arm with
the pipette and magnetic rods for
reagent transfers and magnetic bead
collections and processing
the system has a
vision system which
will track the reagents and consumables
for their correct loading
and also expiration
the instrument has a uv light for first
run decontamination
to prevent any cross-contamination
between runs
and after the runs
the quantitation results can be
downloaded along with the run logs
through the usb port available on the
instrument
the genexis purification system uses the
legacy magmax
technology
where a magnetic rod is used to collect
the magnetic beads that are bound to the
nucleic acid
in order to prevent the contamination of
the magnetic rod
and also as apparatus
for mixing we use this plastic
consumable called tip combs
the tip comp will cover the magnetic rod
and once the
magnetic rod covered by the tip comb is
lowered to the solution that contains
the magnetic beads
that are bound to nucleic acid
those can be collected by magnetizing
the magnetic rod
next you can move that collected
magnetic beads to different wells
by taking the magnetic rod out of the
well and moving into a different well
and also the magnetic rod can be moved
away from the tip comb
and that will release the magnetic beads
that are bound to the nucleic acid
and then the
tip comb can be moved up and down in the
well to mix the
solutions in the well
so this is the concept used in the
genexis purification system
to process the
samples to extract a nucleic acid
the genexis purification system supports
four different purification kits
to process different sample types
the ffe
dna and rna purification kit
the multi-sample dna purification kit
and total rna purification kit supports
12 samples per run
and each kit has
4 runs worth consumables to process 48
samples
the genexis self-rate total nucleic acid
kit
supports six samples per run and has
four runs worth consumables supporting
24 samples per kit
the ffe purification kit
can process
surgical resections cnbs that are
corneal biopsy fna fine needle aspirates
and extract dna and rna sequentially or
dna and rna
separately
the multi-sample dna and total rna kits
can process multiple types of samples
to extract genomic dna or total
rna the genexis cell free nucleic acid
purification kit
a processes a plasma from whole blood
to extract a total nucleic acid
from the sample
these different nucleic acid outputs can
be used in
downstream
at ngs research assays depending on your
need and applicability
the genexis purification kits are used
in combination with the nucleic acid
quantitation kit and the genexis supply
skit
the genexis nucleic acid quantitation
kit contains the invitrogen cubit
dna high sensitivity or dna broad range
assays for dna
quantitation and for rna quantitation
it has the qubit rna broad range assay
reagents
and all your consumables
that are pipette tips the 4812 pcr plate
for sample storage will be provided in
the supply skid
now i will walk you through
how to plan run
when the genexis purification system is
used in the standalone mode
so here you plan your run on the
instrument using the user interface
here is the home screen
and this is a touch screen so
to start you
touch the run button
and that will prompt you to the
all the plan runs in this instrument
so if you want to reuse one of these run
plans you simply select that
and this button will turn into next and
then it will prompt you to start your
run
with deck loading
if you are creating a new run
you
click on this add plan button
and that will prompt you to give a run
name
of your choice once you do that you go
to the next screen
and then you can select the purification
kit
that you are planning to use
so depending on your sample type you you
will use one of the four
extraction kits available
so once you select your kit in this case
we are we have selected the cell free
total nucleic acid kit and then within
the kit there can be multiple
protocols
for the cell free tn naked there will be
only one
protocol
but if for example if you select the
multi-sample dna kit
there will be multiple protocols
depending on your sample type
after that it will prompt you to select
the elusion volume
and automatically it will be selected
the default elevation volume that is
recommended in the user guide
so if you want to you can change this
uh volume
by using this drop down menu
and also you have the option to
do the quantitation after the
purification
using this button so if you select it
all the samples will be quantified on
board
if you deselect it samples will not be
quantified and you will have to do it
manually after the purification
next
you can edit your sample information
so before editing if you do not have six
samples in this case for your run you
can deselect
the
to match the number of samples you have
for example if you have only four
samples for your run you can deselect
the last two samples
and then also you can edit the sample id
to match your sample if you need more
descriptive
name for your sample
once you select your samples
then you will get a summary of the run
plan that you just created
and if all the information are correct
you can go to the next
if not you can go back to the edit
button and edit the
information needed
so
so that was how
you plan run in the
stand-alone
mode
if you are running the gen xs
purification
in the integrated mode with the
integrated sequencer then all of the
things you did on the instrument you are
doing it on the genexis software
in the
the iron torrent server
so in this case
to plan run
you can
choose
sample to result
option
and enter all the information that we
just discussed
in this run planning
so all these will be done on your
computer
without going to the instrument
so once you plan the run it will prompt
you to load your consumables
gen genexis purification system is
designed to
monitor all the
loading activities using the vision
system
and also the consumables have been
designed
to load in only one orientation
and one location so you it's very hard
to make a mistake with this system
so depending on the workflow and
the protocol you will be asked to load
either
one or multiple
uh 24 d pill plates and 96 d pill plates
each of these consumables has with their
specific locations on the deck
and again depending on the protocol
you will ask to load one or two tip
boxes
and then if
doing quantitation the quantitation
plate will be loaded in this location
and
after loading these consumables
you have to close this latch to lock
these consumables so they will be
kept in place during the workflow
if the instrument is run in standalone
mode all the nucleic acid
will be
end up in this 48-wheel archive plate
pcr plate
if you are
doing the run in integrated mode
depending on the
the sequencing assay
the amount required will be transferred
from the 48-wheel archive plate to 96
well output plate and this 96 well
output plate will be
loaded onto the integrated sequencer
as i mentioned before the vision system
can identify
the presence of foil
foil seal on the plates
and also it can detect incorrect
consumables or expired consumables
this is
due to
the presence of bar codes in the
consumables and the vision system can
read them
and identify if they are expired or if
they are incorrect consumables
so here is an example
when it is guided to load these plates
we have
purposefully
loaded these two plates
with foil
so you can see the instrument show that
it is incorrect
by
highlighting them in orange color and
also at the end it will prompt
you to correct the error
with the message saying remove the foil
from the from the plate
so once you
correct these errors if present
then the instrument will prompt you to
start the run
once the run is completed
the quantitation results can be
obtained
on the instrument user interface if it
is a standalone run
and then
these data can be exported to a usb and
then downloaded
if the run is
done on the integrated mode
then all the concentration data will be
available on the
the torrent server
and all the concentration values can be
found in this
manner
and if any of the concentrations are
below the
the assay requirement
it will be flagged as
quantity not sufficient so the user can
decide whether to move forward
or not
depending on the
need
next we will
walk through the ffve dna rna
purification kit and the workflow
to extract a nucleic acid from a ffe
sample
the ffe blocks
has to be pre-processed
to get a lysate
the ffe samples come in different uh
shapes and size of the blocks
and these can be either tumor resections
fine needle spirits or co-needle
biopsies
the first thing to do is to
cut
thin curls from these blocks
for that we use the micro tom and then
for the genexis
system we recommend using 5 to 10
micrometer curls
once you have the curls curls can be
processed as is or they can be mounted
on slides
this is required if if the samples has
to be
has to undergo histological staining
to get tissue and tumor contents
if not they can be processed directly as
a curl
to process curls or slides
the recommended method
for genexis system is the
applied biosystems ortalis m
tubes this is a semi-automated system
which i will discuss
further in the next slide
and if it is if using conventional
methods such as
xylene and citrus oil method
those can be
processed in uh normal offend of tubes
and after uh departurization protein sk
digestion and decross linking
these can be
used the lysate can be used to extract
nucleic acid
the the advantage of using the
semi-automated
the autoless m tubes is that they do not
require any organic solvent
this is important since
some countries are already restricting
use of these uh harsh organic solvent
for processing ffve samples
so the waterless tube
has two parts outer and inner tube the
sample
is the curls
all the scrapped curl from the slide
will be added to the inner tube
and then the protein sk solution will be
added to the tube
and
that will be incubated at 60 degrees for
one hour
for departmenization and protein sk
digestion
which happens simultaneously
next the tube will be put it put under
90
degrees for one hour
for the cross linking
after that
the inner tube will be lift halfway
and then the tube will be centrifuged
to separate the lysate
from the paraffin
the way it does
in the orderless tube is it has a filter
and once you centrifuge the lysate will
come down to the
the outer tube
and the paraffin will stay with the
filter
after you are done with that
the tube will be lifted all the way
and the lysate can be collected from the
outer tube
so in order to do that this process you
need some additional
items such as the orderless tube rack
which uh used to
centrifuge these tubes and then also the
tube locking lid
which keeps the
the
inner tube in place during the
centrifugation
and to lift these
tubes
either you can use pliers
or
the waterless tube lifter which can lift
multiple tubes at a time
so here is an overview of the whole
process of extracting
the dna and rna from
ffa samples
so the preprocessing is what i described
and once you have the lysate you add the
lysate to the plate one of the ffv dna
rna purification kit
and also
you have to make a
dna's master mix using the reagents
provided in the kit and add that
to the plate 2 of the
kit and these two plates will be then be
loaded to the purification system along
with the consumables
to extract the dna
dna and rna
so we we discuss about the preprocessing
steps and what happens on board
is
highlighted in blue here
if if
extracting both dna and rna sequentially
from the sample
the dna is first going to bind with the
beads
due to the preferential
binding nature in the buffer we are
using
and then
the
the dna will be
washed and eluted
the rna will be retained in the
supernatant and then it will be bound to
new beads and washed
and any remaining dna will be digested
with dna
and
the clean rna will be then rebound
washed and eluted to get rna
so in the right i am showing
the the fragment profiles of dna and rna
from
ffe
samples
so as you can see
you can see a nice intact fragments of
ffpe
and the intensity of the
signal increases with the
tissue input here
and that is true
for rna as well in the bottom
bioanalyzer graph
next we will work i will walk you
through the cell free total nucleic acid
purification kit workflow
isolating cell free nucleic acid
from plasma is a non-invasive method to
detect biomarkers however
it has its own challenges compared to
other sample types
the major challenge is its low abundance
because of the low abundance we need
large amount of input
to extract sufficient amount of
cell free tna
and the next challenge is the
degradation
uh during the storage and the processing
so the expected amount
of cftna
you as you can see especially rna is
really
low
uh from
from a sample
so these
challenges also depends on a
few factors some of them can be
sample or donor dependent
such as health of the subject or the
stage of the cancer
or if they are undergoing treatment the
status of the treatment
those things we cannot really control
however
what we can control is the storage and
sample processing
storage is important and especially when
uh selecting a tube type
to collect the whole blood
uh it
it can be really important decision
because some of the tubes they do have
preservation preservatives
to preserve either cf dna or rna or both
that can help reduce the
degradation of
free material
and the other important aspect is the
time from collection to processing this
is really important and i will show an
example in the next slide
and depending on how long your storage
store the samples the storage
temperature is also important
and then to get a meaningful amount of
cftna in good condition
the method of extraction the
quantitation
and also what type of analysis method
you are using downstream is
really important
so when working with
cell free tna
so the blood
collection tube as i said is really
important
and also if you are using a
tube like k2 edta
these samples have to be kept cold
at all times
and the other thing to avoid this freeze
though this is mainly to avoid the
rupturing of the cells during these
freestyle cycles and rupturing of these
cells will lead to releasing of genomic
dna which you do not need
in this type of extraction
and for long term storage we recommend
storing samples at minus atc
and as i said before the processing time
from the collection is really important
so here is an example
to show that
how delayed processing can increase the
amount of
genomic dna
over time
which can negatively affect the
downstream application when using cfdna
to separate plasma from whole blood
generally a two step centrifugation
has to take place
first at 2000 g for 10 minutes at 4c
then the plasma is separated from the
whole blood and undergo another
centrifugation
to further separate any cell debris
present in the plasma
at higher
speed
here you can do either 16000 g for 10
minutes or 6000 g for 30 minutes
so once you have the plasma separated
it's really easy to set up the
extraction run
using the genexis
purification system
where you only have to add the protein
sk a solution to the sample and just mix
it
and then add the
the binding buffer to the plate
and then
transfer your sample to the same plate
and load onto the instrument
once you load onto the instrument
since we are processing large amount of
sample up to eight milliliters of plasma
in these runs
first it will bind to
the tna
and then wash it an elliot in a larger
volume of elusion buffer to make it
efficient
illusion without losing
the small amount of tna present in the
sample
then the elite tna will be concentrated
and then eluted again in a smaller
volume volume that is meaningful to use
in a downstream application such as ngs
so in the right side i am showing
two different
profiles of cftn extractions
and
the one on the top is what we desire
where you only have the cell free dna
and you do not have genomic dna
in this area
in the bottom graph is
something
that we do not want where you have a lot
of contamination of the genomic dna
so this can be due to any of those steps
we had talked about before
starting from sample collection up to
the
extraction
so try to avoid
getting this type of results
for that follow those steps we discussed
and
so that will result in a good
extraction of cell free
nucleic acid and that will lead to a
better
results with the
downstream applications
so with that
i would like to
conclude this presentation
and
take any questions
thank you lanka zuli and andrew for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
lillian manley scientist molecular
biology will be joining us for the q a
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
this was for lillian
when would when would you use a genexis
system
over a kingfisher instrument
thank you so much for the question it's
actually a really good question and
dependent on the workflow your lab
chooses based off of its needs
so both kingfisher and genexis systems
work really nicely with the magmax
chemistry both offer magmax chemistries
as a solution on their extraction
technology and use a similar
standardization however genexa's
solution offers both a pur a
purification as well as a sequencer that
can be split apart and segmented
with that the user guide does specify
very particular sample types and kit
chemistries so depending on your lab's
needs the benefit of utilizing a genexa
system would be to fully automate or
standardize that process by basically
supporting a walk away solution from
sample
down to genexis sequencer with the
genexis sequencer so your sequencing
output
when you choose a kingfisher system if
you needed to process a sample that
maybe wasn't in the genexis
user guide or you needed flexibility
with sample throughput dependent on your
labs needs of course so the kingfisher
systems that zulie went over so
different throughput options scaling
from small to ultra high and several
different
sample types and kit chemistries as she
mentioned as well as in a presentation
um can be offered on the kingfisher
platform
extracting samples on the kingfisher
platform can then be utilized with
either the ion torrent platform using
the s5 system or the genexis sequencer
so essentially you can use it in a
segmented way to
work with the needs of your particular
lab
thank you
and we have time for one more question
this question is for andrew
just want to confirm the background
subtraction trick for reconstructing the
standard curve is simply subtracting the
background readout no sample but only
the die from all the strand dilution
readout
hi
sorry that wasn't clear at first
effectively yes so if you're doing a
qubit workflow you're effectively
subtracting
standard one
the standard one readout from all of
your samples
and if you're doing the quantity
workflow i believe it's standard eight
which should be zero nanograms per
microliter and you're subtracting that
from everything so there should be
no nucleic acid present it'll just have
the working solution
at 200 microliters plus the 10
microliters of the buffered blank
and in general that should be the same
that should be accurate for any of the
dna workflows and any of the rna
workflows
thank you again
great thank you
and thank you again lanka zuli andrew
and lillian for your time today and
wonderful presentations
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you